ERIC KOTEDA: Hello, and
welcome to Google Apps
Unscripted.
This is our renamed Google Apps
Script Office Hours where
we cover news, events related to
App Script, and answer your
questions live.
So if you do happen to be
watching live, you can go to
developers.google.com, click on
the Live link and join us
in a Hangout.
And later in the show, we'll
be taking live questions.
With me today, Kalyan Reddy,
another member of the App
Script team.
KALYAN REDDY: Hello, everyone.
ERIC KOTEDA: And so this is
the start of the new year.
Start of a new year for
Google App Script.
It's been a while since we did
one of our GDLs, one of these
Google Developer
Live episodes.
And we have a little
bit to cover.
So I'd say the first piece of
news is that we are launching
a whole bunch of new
GDL content.
We had a lot of success
last year.
You were on a couple
shows, right?
KALYAN REDDY: Yeah, yeah.
ERIC KOTEDA: I think you
did a charts one?
KALYAN REDDY: Yep,
that's right.
ERIC KOTEDA: Yeah, so that was
very popular actually.
I remember seeing
the view count.
A lot of people liked
the charts episode.
KALYAN REDDY: And we had a
couple of other ones on Twilio
and some of the cool integration
with other
applications.
ERIC KOTEDA: Yeah.
So we've been trying to
bring you guys a lot
of interesting content.
And so we've done some work
to re-brand a little bit.
So as I just already mentioned,
this is kind of
like Google Apps Script Office
Hours re-branded, called
Google Apps Unscripted.
And as you can tell,
we are not very
scripted at the moment.
But we also have two
more really cool
episodes coming up.
So the first is on
February 12th.
That's next week, on Tuesday.
We are going to be holding
State of the Script 2013.
We're riding on the back of
State of the Union address
here in the United States.
Or maybe they're riding our
back, I guess depending upon
which you think is
more important.
And so we're going to be talking
with the product
manager of Google Apps Script,
Saurabh Gupta, who works with
us here in New York.
And he's going to be sitting
down with our colleague Arun
Nagarajan and discussing where
App Script has been this past
year, where we're at, and where
he sees the future of
App Script going.
KALYAN REDDY: Yeah.
So it's a really good idea for
you guys to tune in if you're
curious about some of the new
things, what the direction is,
to sync up with the PM.
ERIC KOTEDA: Yeah.
I mean, how often do you really
get to speak to the
product manager?
Or get to at least hear the
message directly from a
product manager here
at Google?
And so that's a really
exciting one
that's coming up soon.
So put it in your calendars.
We actually have, for
all of our GDLs, a
Google+ event set up.
So if you follow me on Google+,
or you follow Kalyan,
just head over to Google+ and
check out some of the events
that we've shared.
And you can actually follow
it there and get some
information.
The other one we have coming
up next week-- it's a week
chock full with good
episodes--
is another addition of what
we're calling App
Script Crash Course.
So this crash course series that
we're putting together--
so far Arun has been knocking
them out, he's doing a great
job-- is kind of picking a
Google Apps Script technology.
In this upcoming episode,
it's script [? DB. ?]
And just doing a mixture
of introductory
and deep dive content.
KALYAN REDDY: Yeah.
Right in the middle.
ERIC KOTEDA: Yeah.
So if you've used it before,
there's still
a lot of work there.
Because he shows some really
cool integrations and some
best practices.
But if you're also brand new to
some of these technologies,
it's a really great way to
get a holistic overview
of what they do.
So Arun did one a couple
weeks ago maybe.
Last week?
I forget.
KALYAN REDDY: I think
it was last week.
ERIC KOTEDA: Last week.
It felt like a year ago.
But he did one which was on the
content service, which is
a really powerful service
that allows you to serve
up JSON, XML, RSS.
And write app scripts that
produce other machine
consumable code, which as you
can imagine, is very powerful.
I think he showed some really
cool integrations.
Do you remember the ones now?
I'm spacing.
KALYAN REDDY: Yeah.
ERIC KOTEDA: Unscripted.
But anyway, go back onto
YouTube, the Google Developers
channel, and go check out
that previous episode.
You can get a sense
of what this crash
course series is like.
KALYAN REDDY: And so basically,
you could read
through some of the
tutorials we have.
They will cover some
of these tricks.
But it's a good idea to tune
in, get a holistic kind of
view about how to use this.
Here are the recommended
things.
Here's best practices.
This is how we can use it
in a couple of examples.
Just to tie things together.
ERIC KOTEDA: Yeah, I mean,
that's the thing.
There's so many pieces in App
Script, and sometimes it's
hard to fit them together.
KALYAN REDDY: Exactly.
ERIC KOTEDA: So Arun does a
really good job of these
really great demos that show
off what's possible.
And he puts all the source code
up on GitHub afterwards
so you can start tinkering
and playing
around with it yourself.
So do check those out.
Go to Google+, check out the
events that we have there, and
hope you tune in for those.
So just to be clear now, this
show is going to be live.
You cannot call in, but you can
join on Google+ Hangout.
That's on the
developers.google.com page for this.
These other episodes, these
other shows we're doing,
they're more about delivering
information.
So we're not having a
Hangout for those.
So if you want to join a
Hangout, if you want to
interact with us, Google
Apps Unscripted is the
place to go for that.
KALYAN REDDY: This
is your event.
ERIC KOTEDA: All right, cool.
So that's some of the
upcoming events.
But one of the other things we
have to talk about in this
show is release notes.
And we've had a lot of release
notes recently, haven't we?
KALYAN REDDY: Oh yeah.
So if we can check
this out here.
Go to the release notes.
OK, how far back do
we have to go?
All the way in January?
ERIC KOTEDA: Yeah.
I don't know how far
back we want to go.
But let's kind of skim through
some of the more interesting
things that we've done in the
past couple releases.
KALYAN REDDY: Yeah, so if you
had some problems with the
time zones, that's a bug
that cropped up.
But we did work around it.
We did re-implement the existing
functionality, so all
of your scripts should
be good to go now.
ERIC KOTEDA: Yeah.
Remember there were a number of
different time zone related
issues across different
services.
KALYAN REDDY: Yeah, right.
ERIC KOTEDA: And one of our
engineers took up the charge
of trying to squash
them all down.
So he put a lot of time into
fixing how time zones work,
getting rid of some
of the edge cases.
So we did commit a number of
different changes there.
I think there are still maybe
a couple open the issue
tracker for time zone
related issues.
So do continue to bring
this to us.
But we are taking an effort
to stamp those down.
But time zones, they're
tricky.
KALYAN REDDY: Yeah.
ERIC KOTEDA: So we also added
some cool features too.
So I mean, if you look through
our release notes that Kalyan
has up here, the number of bug
fixes which you can see are
all those issue, issue,
issue, issue.
They're pretty large.
We've been trying
to squash bugs.
And the team has been doing a
great job of going through and
putting extra effort
on killing bugs.
No one likes bugs.
It's always really sad when you
put a lot of effort into
building something and
then hit this bug.
And you're like, aww.
You could waste an hour or
you realize you have to
redo what you did.
So they are putting a lot
of time into the bugs.
But simultaneously they're
also still
continuing to add features.
What people love about App
Script, especially me, is that
anything you want to do, there's
a service for it.
Gmail app has a service, Drive,
Docs list service.
KALYAN REDDY: And they're
so easy to use.
ERIC KOTEDA: Yeah.
It's kind of the ultimate
pocket knife of utility.
And so they've been working to
continue to expand that.
And so you'll see some entries
in the release notes around
enhancing the clock
trigger builder.
In the January 17th release
down there.
KALYAN REDDY: Down here?
ERIC KOTEDA: Yeah.
So that was an extra method
that was added in.
It's kind of a convenience to
make it a little bit easier to
build these one off triggers.
And so that was a
really good one.
And then we've also had some
in the one above there.
So one of the things in issue
286 was actually a featured
request on the 24th.
Which was to add a follow
redirects method to URL
fetches apps fetch method.
So essentially I think the way
it used to work is that when
you use URL fetch to request
a URL, if it was doing
redirects, the server that you
were fetching from, you would
always follow those redirects
and you couldn't stop it.
And sometimes people wanted to
actually get the intermediary
HTTP request that had the
redirect code in it and pull
out some information.
KALYAN REDDY: Right.
ERIC KOTEDA: And so with this
follow redirects advanced
argument, you can now
set it to false to
prevent that behavior.
KALYAN REDDY: So it makes the
method more powerful.
You have the option to get
exactly what you want.
ERIC KOTEDA: Yeah,
it's pretty cool.
And right above it, you can see
that we, for UI App, did a
little bit of work so that you
can now do mailto anchors.
So a lot of people want to do
that old-fashioned style
mailto email address that when
you click a link will pop open
your default email client
with that email address
pre-populated.
So we didn't have that
supported UI app
before, but now we do.
So if you want to put a little
link in your app saying some
things are horribly broken,
email Saurabh
Gupta, our PM, directly.
You can do that now.
Although he may not respond
to every request.
And then I think in our 31st
release up above, we have
another feature that we added
which is kind of cool, was a
spreadsheet app that
opened by URL.
That's right there at the top.
And what's great about that one
is that there are a lot of
users who wanted to create some
sort of script that said
just enter your spreadsheet
URL here and I'll do some
processing on it.
But then you needed to do some
Regex work to find the key
parameter and pull it out.
I actually did this in a couple
script that I wrote.
And it's a little bit of extra
work that's kind of annoying.
So now what you can do is if you
have your user just paste
in a spreadsheet URL, we'll
figure out which spreadsheet
ID that is and open it up for
you without you needing to do
any extra parsing.
KALYAN REDDY: And even for
yourself, when you're creating
these quick scripts, you don't
want to extract the key and
copy things into a variable
and everything.
This makes it much more easy,
much more polished.
ERIC KOTEDA: Yeah.
So that's a fun little feature
that's added in there.
You can see we also did a little
more work on a clock
trigger builder, time zones.
Time zones.
KALYAN REDDY: Yeah, another
time zone issue.
This one, the problem was that
it was actually defaulting to
Pacific time.
But now we've fixed it so that
it does respect the time zone
that you've enabled
in your script.
ERIC KOTEDA: Yeah, and if you
haven't done a lot with App
Script before or especially
around time
zones, it can get confusing.
Because a spreadsheet
has a time zone.
A script has a time zone.
Your Google calendars have
their own time zone.
Our servers have their own.
So we try to keep it all
separate and make sense and
try to make inter-operate
as best as possible.
But there definitely are these
little cases where if you take
a time zone from here or a date
from here and pass it
over there, what does it mean?
Which time zone are
you talking about?
It can get a little tricky,
so we're still
hammering those out.
KALYAN REDDY: Right.
ERIC KOTEDA: And then one of
the ones here you'll see in
the January 31st release was
the ability for the code
editor's find dialog to search
through multiple files in your
App Scrip project.
This is really cool because a
lot of times I'll know I have
some key or some variable that I
know I need to replace maybe
in a bunch of places.
But I didn't know
where I put it.
And so before, find and replace
would only work on
your single file.
But now it works on multiples.
KALYAN REDDY: And this is really
handy, because users
now are having larger scripts,
more complicated scripts.
So they're breaking out the
logic into different files, as
you should to tackle
the complexity.
And this enables you to
develop more easily.
ERIC KOTEDA: Yeah.
So the editor we have in App
Script, it's obviously not as
full featured as in Eclipse or
Sublime Text is a popular one
here in the office.
It's not quite up to that
level of complexity yet.
But we are working on constantly
improving the
experience.
Because we do know that although
sometimes you write
an App Script and you're just
trying to get something done
quickly and you don't
need to have as
many advanced features.
But a lot of people writing App
Scripts today are doing
very complex projects.
Big web apps or big
workflow systems.
And so having these extra
features really can
save a lot of time.
KALYAN REDDY: Definitely.
ERIC KOTEDA: All right.
Anything else for the release
notes you wanted
to highlight, Kalyan?
KALYAN REDDY: I think those
are the main things.
And as you can see, a
ton of bug fixes.
So definitely keep on bringing
them up on the issue tracker.
That's the major source for
how we can find out about
these things.
We'll triage them and then
we'll get them fixed
as soon as we can.
ERIC KOTEDA: That's great.
All right, cool.
So I think that brings us to
the question and answer
portion of the show.
KALYAN REDDY: Yeah.
ERIC KOTEDA: Apps Unscripted.
So we have some questions here
on the Google Moderator page.
And it looks like we have some
Hangout participants as well.
So let's see who's on the
Hangout first and if we have
any live questions.
Hello and welcome to
Apps Unscripted.
Anybody?
Anybody there have a question?
KALYAN REDDY: Or just
want to say hi?
ERIC KOTEDA: Yeah.
Or just want to say hi.
HARRY: I want to say hi.
ERIC KOTEDA: Oh hey!
KALYAN REDDY: Hey there.
HARRY: And I have a question.
ERIC KOTEDA: Sure, go ahead.
HARRY: OK.
My name's Harry [INAUDIBLE]
from Netherlands.
My question is, when you want to
cooperate on a project, on
a script, we've managed so far
to do it only when you both
login under the same name.
ERIC KOTEDA: Yeah.
HARRY: So it's apparently only
the owner of script can run it
in development mode.
ERIC KOTEDA: Yeah.
So that is a known problem that
I know actually Kalyan
ran into with our
colleague Arun.
They were trying to collaborate
on a script.
And there are definitely some
problems around collaborating
on a script today.
One of the ones you mentioned is
that if you're deploying it
as a web app, only the owner can
deploy it as the web app
or update the version that's
being deployed.
And even if you're an editor,
you can't do that today.
It's only the owner.
So that is something that we've
raised before with the
engineering team.
And I think we should push
even harder on that.
Because collaboration is
something that's very
important at Google.
You know, Google Docs, that's
the main selling point is
having two little cursors
fly around the
doc at the same time.
KALYAN REDDY: And it's something
you expect from the
platform as a whole, right?
So that's a great feature.
That collaboration is
just baked into
so many of our services.
ERIC KOTEDA: So I think we'd
really love to bring more of
that to Google App Script.
I think that the way the editor
is built today, we may
not be able to get to that exact
point that Google Docs
has where two cursors are
flying around the screen
simultaneously.
But I think we can definitely
improve the experience around
deploying web apps and around
even just editing different
files within the same project
at the same time.
So I'll make a note right now
to bring that topic up again
in some of our meetings.
Because I definitely want to
make sure that collaboration
is something that we do
support in App Script.
KALYAN REDDY: Yeah.
And also, you might have
experienced some problems with
the revision history isn't as
fine grained as something you
would expect in spreadsheets
or documents.
We're looking into that.
And we're looking into
making the experience
much better for users.
ERIC KOTEDA: Yeah.
Yeah, I think App Script has
been growing from a product
that one person used to create
one small thing to now it is a
team platform sometimes.
We'll have to grow into some
of these features, I think.
Great.
KALYAN REDDY: Anyone else?
ERIC KOTEDA: Yeah.
Or another question
from Harry?
All right, great.
So stay on the line, guys.
We'll keep your audio up.
If you have a question, feel
free to jump in, in between.
And if people are watching and
don't feel like joining live
to ask a question, you're more
than welcome to go to our
Google Moderator that's
embedded in the
developers.google.com
page for this event.
All right, so let's go
to the Moderator.
So we have some questions
here.
I've got them up on my screen.
But you don't need
to see them.
I'll just read them out loud.
So the first one we have
here is a question
from Jonathan in London.
He says, will the number
of scripts that can
simultaneously be authorized,
will that be increased?
They're doing some really useful
work around Google App
Script and triggers.
And the current authorization
limit work around that they're
using is to trigger a single
script with other scripts used
as libraries.
And it's a bit messy.
So there is a problem today.
The problem is that we have the
limits around the number
of App Script projects that can
authorize against some of
our services.
So I don't know if you noticed
in App Script, sometimes when
you do an authorization
screen, it pops up.
Where you're running your script
for the first time or
deploying it as a web app, you
get a screen that says, here's
all the different things
we're going to use.
Hit authorize.
Then sometimes you'll get
to a second screen.
That second screen is actually
the standard
Google OAuth screen.
And there you're configuring
some
access to specific services.
I know Gmail is one that
requires this.
KALYAN REDDY: Right.
ERIC KOTEDA: You're
saying sites
require it in some cases.
KALYAN REDDY: Yes, certain types
of interactions where
you need authorization with
sites will prompt
you for that as well.
And there are other examples.
ERIC KOTEDA: Any scripts that
require that secondary prompt,
unfortunately it's kind of built
into the system right
now that there's a limit, which
is I think somewhere
around 15 or 20--
I forget the exact number--
totals that can be authorized
at any one time.
If you authorize a new one,
you'll kick out an old one.
And I think that's probably
what Jonathan is
running into here.
We are actually actively working
on changing the back
end to make this go away.
We don't like it, you
don't like it.
And 15 is an arbitrarily
small number.
So we're definitely working
on getting rid of this.
As you can imagine, the Google
systems and the Google
infrastructure, everything's
tied together in very
complicated ways.
So we are working and switching
out some components
to make this go away.
And I don't know exactly when
it'll be complete, but it is
something we're working on.
All right, so let's
go to another
question here in the Moderator.
So this is John Mark in Belgium
asking, where are the
servers that store data
for Script EB or even
Google Drive Docs?
Where are those servers
located?
Will it be possible to locate
them exclusively in Europe
like Google App Engine does?
I do not believe we have control
over those today.
KALYAN REDDY: Yeah.
I don't think so.
ERIC KOTEDA: Yeah.
So I do know that the
intersection of technology and
government can lead to some
strange things sometimes.
And I do know that in some
countries, depending upon what
you're doing, if it's government
related services or
systems, your data needs to be
located physically within
certain country boundaries
or certain geopolitical
boundaries.
And so I think what they're
referencing here is a Google
App Engine.
I'm not familiar, but I'll take
their word on it, has the
ability to say, make sure that
the servers you spin up are
only located in a
certain country.
For Google App Script, we
don't have that ability.
KALYAN REDDY: And it's kind
of like a hidden feature.
A lot of these things, we
simplify these underlying
systems just so that people can
get in, write a script, do
what they want to do.
We try to hide this
complexity.
And it's like a balance on how
much you do want to show and
how much users should worry
about on a regular basis.
ERIC KOTEDA: Yeah.
Yeah.
It's [INAUDIBLE].
Like for App Script, we're
trying to be simple.
We're trying to be fast.
If everyone who wanted to run
a quick script against their
Gmail account had to choose a
server farm, it definitely
hurts the experience.
So I can understand where
you're coming from.
I think probably though, it's
not something you're going to
see from App Script, at least
in the short term.
Where we're trying to be is in
a place that's not quite as
complex as that.
And so if Google App Engine
meets your needs, I'd say keep
going with that for now.
KALYAN REDDY: Yeah.
ERIC KOTEDA: All right.
Let me just toss it over to
the Hangout one more time.
Is anybody there with another
question they
want to chime in with?
NEIL HENDON: Yeah.
Quick request.
ERIC KOTEDA: Sure.
NEIL HENDON: I'm a new
App Script user.
So thank you very much.
I love using it.
Could maybe a better
documentation on what values
are passed to functions embedded
in a spreadsheet?
Because let's say you're trying
to rewrite say, the sum
function, you could take
individual values, cells, a
range, or a combination
of all three.
And that creates some fairly
complicated arguments to that
function that you're
trying to write.
So it's a little unclear.
Say you were trying to write a
version of the sum function in
sheets that used say,
geometric mean
or some other math.
ERIC KOTEDA: OK.
NEIL HENDON: To write it
properly, you have to handle a
large variety of arguments.
ERIC KOTEDA: I see.
NEIL HENDON: And so the
documentation is a little
sparse on that.
ERIC KOTEDA: Yeah, no.
That's a really good pointer.
You've probably seen our
documentation now.
There's a lot there.
And we're actually working with
our technical writer--
NEIL HENDON: Oh, I agree.
ERIC KOTEDA: Yeah.
We're working with our technical
writer now to work
on not just producing
more, but really
refining what we have.
So as you found out, there's
a lot of information, but
sometimes some of that basic
information can get lost in
the sauce or isn't the first
place you'd look, or maybe
isn't there at all.
Just off the top my head, I
happen to know that I think in
most cases, a range
will get sent down
as an array of values.
Versus a single cell will get
sent down as the value itself.
If it's a date, it'll get
sent down as a date.
NEIL HENDON: That's what I
found, but I had to find that
by experimentation.
ERIC KOTEDA: Exactly.
KALYAN REDDY: Right, right.
NEIL HENDON: I needed
to write several
versions of a function.
One of which worked
on horizontal
ranges, but not vertical.
And one that worked on
2D ranges but not 1D.
So there are a lot of special
cases, so maybe some better
examples would be helpful.
ERIC KOTEDA: That's
a really good tip.
NEIL HENDON: For new users.
ERIC KOTEDA: Yeah, no.
That's a great tip.
KALYAN REDDY: Yeah,
definitely.
ERIC KOTEDA: Yeah.
One of the things we're also
talking about now with our
documentation is trying to
streamline it towards specific
users and specific use cases.
So we know that a really large
segment of our users are
people who want to do
custom functions.
And we don't really have a
really great start to finish
track for them where they can
go from nothing to being a
custom functions expert.
So we want to make it so that
if that's what you're
interested in, we take
you start to finish
a little bit more.
Instead of right now
we're kind of like,
welcome and good luck.
We're going to refine that and
that's really great feedback.
Thank you.
I didn't catch your
name, by the way.
NEIL HENDON: Oh, Neil Hendon.
Thank you.
ERIC KOTEDA: OK, thanks Neil.
Oh, great.
Since we're on the Hangout, does
anybody else feel like
jumping in?
Question?
Comment?
GRANT: Yeah.
This is Grant from Cleveland.
So the question I have is, is
there a way to centrally
manage an App Script that goes
out to multiple copies of a
spreadsheet?
The use case I have is I've
got a template spreadsheet
that's with App Script
built into it.
And all of the employees
here would have to
make a copy of that.
And they use the App
Script every day.
But if I need to make a change
to that or improve it in any
way, I have to go in manually to
each individual spreadsheet
and change the code there.
So is there a way to manage it
centrally so you can push out
the changes to all of it?
ERIC KOTEDA: Yeah, that's
a great question.
That's actually one that
we get a lot too.
KALYAN REDDY: So
would libraries
help in this situation?
ERIC KOTEDA: Libraries is
one way that can help.
So one of the people I reference
a lot in my posts is
out one of our power users here
in New York that we pow
wow with sometimes is
Andrew Stillman.
He works for New Visions, which
works with the public
schools here in New York.
And he uses App Script a lot
and he has this exact same
problem, where you are
one author, but then
there's a lot of users.
And how do you as the author
be able to make updates
without having each user have to
make a new copy of a sheet
or copy paste code?
We don't have a perfect
solution today.
One of the things that helps is
libraries that Kalyan mentioned.
A library allows you to
write one script and
import it into others.
And so the only caveat there,
and the thing that makes it
imperfect for this particular
scenario, is that we have a
concept of versions
on libraries.
So this is good in that, if
you had a library you were
dispersing to many people,
let's say you changed a
function around, you changed the
behavior, you changed the
order of the parameters, it
would be bad if your change
broke everybody else who wasn't
expecting it all at once.
So instead what we do is we
snapshot your library in a
period of time.
And when someone uses your
library, they don't just use
the library.
They use a specific version.
So in this scenario, you could
have all of these spreadsheets
have scripts that
use the library.
And then when you push that
new version of the library
out, you still have to inform
your users to go into the
script editor, go to the
libraries menu, and change the
version from two to three,
three to four, et cetera.
KALYAN REDDY: It's just
a little bit--
I don't want to say cleaner.
But it's a little bit easier
for the user than making a
copy and then dealing with
all that other stuff.
ERIC KOTEDA: Yeah.
It is an improvement.
KALYAN REDDY: It's a
little bit better.
HARRY: [INAUDIBLE]?
ERIC KOTEDA: Say that again?
HARRY: Can I share my
solution for this?
ERIC KOTEDA: Oh, sure.
Go ahead.
HARRY: You can start with a
spreadsheet and add a script
to the spreadsheet.
But the alternative is to start
with a plain script
which you share with
all your users.
And then you set the ID or the
URL of the spreadsheet in one
of the user properties.
ERIC KOTEDA: Mmm.
HARRY: So everybody's own
spreadsheet, but you all use
the same copy of the script.
ERIC KOTEDA: And so how do
you deploy that script?
HARRY: I have scripts which
works a bit like that, yeah.
ERIC KOTEDA: But do they
have a user interface?
Or are they just running them
from the script editor?
HARRY: The script is a way
where you add a tech to a
Gmail and then you export
it to Evernote.
ERIC KOTEDA: Gotcha.
HARRY: And the first time
you run it, it creates a
spreadsheet where the
transactions are locked.
Then you remember that idea
in the properties.
I have no clue how many
people are using it.
Quite a lot.
But it's all the same
copy, yeah.
ERIC KOTEDA: Right.
So that's actually a great
alternative, and one that we
recommended sometimes in the
past, which is that instead of
thinking of it as each
spreadsheet has its own
script, there's just one
script that operates in
multiple spreadsheets.
So it's kind of flipping on its
head the paradigm here.
And we've seen ways in the
past where you could, for
instance, create one script that
you deploy as a web app.
And so instead of somebody in
the spreadsheet accessing a
menu that pops up a dialogue,
they just type in a URL--
or probably it's a too
long to type--
but they take that URL, and it
shows them a UI where they say
which spreadsheet would you
like me to operate on?
And they can configure it from
one central location.
And then that central location
reaches out to all the
spreadsheets it wants
to manipulate.
It's a little harder to wrap
your head around if you've
been used to building scripts
inside a spreadsheet.
KALYAN REDDY: The
container bound.
ERIC KOTEDA: Yeah, the
But it does fix this problem.
But anyway, it's a problem
that's still open.
We still have people wanting a
better solution, and we're
still talking about
better solutions.
So we hope to keep coming up
with more alternatives to
libraries and to this that would
make it so that people
in your situation have an easier
way to do updates.
KALYAN REDDY: Mm hmm.
HARRY: I have shared a blog
post to the link of
the script I used.
ERIC KOTEDA: Oh great.
MALE SPEAKER: [INAUDIBLE].
ERIC KOTEDA: All right, I want
to make sure we get through at
least one more or two more
in the Moderator.
So if you're on the Hangout,
just wait a second.
I want to make sure, because
people did vote on the
Moderator and we actually have
some good votes on here.
So one of the ones that got
voted very highly was from
Alan, and he didn't say where.
He said, are there any examples
of using do posts
that can read non-form submitted
content such as
application JSON?
All the examples I've seen
assume form submissions or
they don't need to
access the body.
Oh, very interesting.
Yeah, I think the do post we
have today is specifically--
and if you don't know, this is
a way that your script can
react to a post request instead
of just a get request.
But I think the do post today
does expect URL forming
encoded, I'm assuming.
It parses the data that comes
in to the post request and
puts it into the eDOT
parameters.
Or I guess, puts it into
the parameters field
of the event object.
Anyway, you can read more
about this in our
documentation.
But I believe it probably does
have to be URL form encoded
and not just applications
JSON.
You know, if you have a really
compelling use case for this--
do you?
KALYAN REDDY: Yeah.
I'm not actually sure.
I remember dealing with this a
little bit ago, but I don't
have it on the top of my head.
I'll have to go back
and look at it.
ERIC KOTEDA: OK.
We can dig in this a
little bit more.
That was my gut feeling, but
I'm not actually 100% sure.
But if you have a really
compelling use case, like you
have some integration that
relies on this, or there's
something really cool you could
do if you had this, open
a feature request.
Give us some background
about why it's useful,
what you use it for.
And we can take it
to the team.
KALYAN REDDY: Yep.
ERIC KOTEDA: Great.
And then one more from Alan that
got voted up was what are
best practices for debugging
inside of a doGet doPost?
That's very interesting.
KALYAN REDDY: So one thing
is, if your doGet has the
parameter e or whatever,
you can't run
in the script editor.
But oftentimes, you can remove
that just for test purposes
and actually run it within the
script editor if you're not
relying on parameters coming
in from the get request.
So you can go through your
script and make sure that all
the services you're calling are
returning the information
you want and you're processing
it the way you want.
ERIC KOTEDA: Right.
Yeah actually, what I've done
in the past around that is
I've left my doGet the same,
excepting an event parameter.
And let's say I'm relying
on certain
parameters inside there.
I'll create a test function
that just creates
a fake event object--
KALYAN REDDY: Yep.
ERIC KOTEDA: Populating
some parameters.
And then pass that fake event
object into a call to doGet.
And it allows me in the script
editor to let it do the
processing.
And I can test out what happens,
log certain messages,
maybe even debug.
Now if you want to actually test
a live page with clicking
and all that, it's absolutely
not going to work.
You can't run the debugger when
you're in the middle of a
live request.
But you can do some things like
do logging is one thing,
if you use a logger service.
[INAUDIBLE]
get some information
as you're going.
That's some basic debugging.
Occasionally if you need to
collect even more data, I'll
do some logging to a spreadsheet
if I'm having a
real big problem and the logger
doesn't hold enough
information.
But I don't know if
there's really a--
I know some web platforms like
Apache, Tomcats, I think you
can do live tying
of the debugger
into the actual running--
KALYAN REDDY: Oh, you can
actually simulate the request
coming in and then stop
it and then stop it.
ERIC KOTEDA: Yeah, exactly.
So you can't do that
with App Scripts.
So if you're used to advanced
debugging, we're
not quite there yet.
But if there's something that
you find is lacking with the
debugging techniques, we
do have a page in our
documentation around
troubleshooting.
So if you think that we don't
cover doGet enough there
today, open a feature request
for us and we'll enhance our
documentation a little
bit there.
KALYAN REDDY: Definitely.
ERIC KOTEDA: All right,
I think we are just
about out of time.
Let's throw to the Hangout one
more time just because I want
to make sure we don't leave
people hanging.
So is there anybody else on the
Hangout with a question?
MALE SPEAKER: I've got one.
ERIC KOTEDA: OK, go ahead.
KALYAN REDDY: Yeah, go ahead.
GRANT: A quickie, and very
likely outside the scope.
I just started using Python
to access spreadsheets.
And of course, the first thing
I ran into was inability to
find any of the Python
documentation because you all
moved everything except the
Python documentation.
And then when I did find the
Python documentation and
examples, the last update
to it was I think
some time in 2010.
I was able to get it running,
and it runs fine.
But the current example does
not support, I guess, OR.
So I was able to get it
running with a single
authorization account.
But I could not make it
run with a two factor
authentication account.
And at least the example that
I showed, that I got, called
directly into a complete
Google library.
So there was nothing
to substitute.
ERIC KOTEDA: I see.
MALE SPEAKER: So it left me with
saying, OK well, I can
figure this out for plain
off accounts but I can't
figure it out for--
ERIC KOTEDA: Two factor.
MALE SPEAKER: Dual
off account.
Because it's not something that
it's telling me to put
this client on my side.
It's something that
it's calling into.
ERIC KOTEDA: Right, right.
Yeah, so unfortunately, App
Script, we don't deal with
that particular product.
I mean, I can talk to some of
the guys who I think would
know where those documentation
ended up, and see if they can
help fix that.
As a quick aside, I actually
do happen to know a way you
can use a two factor account.
And it's called the
application specific passwords.
So if you have a two factor
account, one of things you can
configure in your Google
account settings is our
application specific
passwords.
MALE SPEAKER: I'll
give that a shot.
ERIC KOTEDA: Yeah.
They act just like as
if you had a single
password in the past.
And so you can just feed that
in where you'd feed in a
single password.
And then you don't need to worry
about the whole one time
password system at all.
MALE SPEAKER: Yeah.
Unfortunately, that has some
other complications in terms
of having to be continuously
recognized as the same thing.
ERIC KOTEDA: Gotcha.
Well unfortunately, we can't
help you too much more there.
MALE SPEAKER: I thought I would
probably [INAUDIBLE].
ERIC KOTEDA: Doesn't
hurt to ask.
Why not?
Before we wrap up, any
last questions?
All right.
Well, we'll be back
again next month.
We're going to try to do
these monthly now.
We did them a lot more
frequently in the past, these
question and answers.
But it's a lot better
when we have good
attendance like we had today.
Thanks everyone for tuning in.
KALYAN REDDY: Yeah.
ERIC KOTEDA: So we'll
be holding one
of these next month.
So if you have any questions in
the meantime, ask them on
Stack Overflow.
That's where we do question
and answer on App Script.
We actually have a fairly
new support page in our
documentation that lists all the
different ways you can get
support, including Stack
Overflow, how to file bugs,
feature requests, going to a
discussion, Google+ community.
So go to that page,
check it out.
If you have any questions until
then, Stack Overflow.
Otherwise, we'll see you
probably next month for
another episode.
KALYAN REDDY: Yeah.
And we'll definitely put
the time and the
link on our Plus pages.
So subscribe to that, add
it to your calendars.
ERIC KOTEDA: Yeah.
Follow us both on Google+
and you'll
definitely get all the updates.
KALYAN REDDY: Yeah.
ERIC KOTEDA: All right, thanks
a lot everybody.
KALYAN REDDY: Thanks.